the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over and
and we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones in
House of the dragon video in this video
we will be looking at the final episode
from House of the dragon's first season
after waiting for well over three years
for House of the Dragon to finally air
on HBO the first season is already over
and I must say I am sad to see it go I
think it's safe to say all of us have
been eagerly awaiting for this final
episode because we've all been wondering
how it would end however with that being
said I don't think any of us actually
want it to be over either now as I have
said in my other videos I will not be
leaving the internet now that house of
the dragon's first season has ended like
I did during the Run of Game of Thrones
I will be here still making videos every
single week even if HBO announces it
will be another five years before House
of the Dragon airs its second season I
will still make videos during that long
night I mean after all this is what I do
and this is what I will always do unless
one day HBO decides they want to have me
exiled from the realm so if you're a
major fan of Game of Thrones in-house of
the Dragon and don't go anywhere just
yet I actually have over 100 different
video ideas saved in my notes on my
phone that I was never able to make
during this season and that list grows
longer every day I was hoping I could
have made even more videos during the
season but there's only so many hours in
the day since it will most likely be
over a year before we finally see The
Following season of House of the Dragon
I will begin making all of those videos
this week and for the foreseeable future
now as you all know House of the Dragon
season 1 finale will show us what
happens after rainera finally learns her
father has died and aegon has ascended
the Iron Throne without her knowledge
like we saw in Game of Thrones we will
see Westeros and its major houses
descend into madness as everyone fights
over who they believe is the rightful
error and once again as you all know in
the Game of Thrones you either win or
you die there is no middle ground now
before we get started I have to let all
of you know about this awesome game that
has some interesting similarities to
House of the Dragon I'd like to thank
the sponsor today's video bloodline
Heroes of lethus if you don't already
play bloodline now is the time to do so
because the game just got the biggest
update ever the newly added hybrid
system is mind-blowing bloodline has one
of the most Unique Mechanics I've ever
seen download the game with my link in
the description or simply scan the QR
code you see on the screen or use my
promo code to get a special starter pack
for the next 30 days bloodline Heroes
elithus is a strategic card based RPG
where you can not only collect Champions
and build kingdoms but also create
Half-Blood errors of your houses by
merging the powers of various Bloodlines
such as demigods Dragonborn Orcs elves
lichens and more you will collect
Champions while you're building up your
kingdom and its economy and then you can
customize your Champions through their
unique marriage system to create over
800 different new hybrids between any
two Bloodlines not only inheriting their
talents and traits but also their unique
appearances passed down from each family
tree and merged into one you will want
to mix your strongest Bloodlines to one
another to create the strongest possible
Offspring and then continue the process
for generations to empower your house in
different ways you can also freely swap
the gender of your Champions new fantasy
characters are being released into the
game every month which means that the
possibilities are endless for you to
seek out the best and the greatest
cyborg Champion to suit your style
nothing beats this new vampire Clan the
accursed which is coming to the game as
a brand new lineage of your bloodline
this Halloween they are the darkest and
most terrifying assassins yet to be
found in the world of lethus an undead
clan that Rose alongside the dark elves
From the Ashes of their homeland's
cataclysm these wrath Lords were cursed
by the dark ritual that has given them
an insatiable thirst for blood they can
not only nuke your enemy but also
sustain themselves on the battlefield
during longer fights by participating in
the Halloween event starting October
27th you will be able to obtain in a
cursed Champion for free on your seventh
day of playing bloodline Heroes elithus
is available for free on both Android
and iOS devices download the game with
my link in the description or simply
scan the QR code you see on the screen
to get a special starter pack worth
twenty dollars including 10 energy
points 100 000 gold and 100 diamonds for
the next 30 days once again I would like
to thank bloodline for sponsoring
today's video
House of the Dragon season 1 finale
begins with a shot of the table on
Dragonstone as you all know this is the
same one that was here on Dragonstone
when Stannis and then Daenerys was
living here it has been here since the
very first aegon had it made years
before he United Westeros now rhaenyra
and Damon will make great use of it as
they decide how they will defeat their
enemies and get the iron throne the
final episode also begins with a very
interesting conversation raniera has
with her son lucari's in this scene he
reveals he doesn't think he deserves the
island of driftmark although he's only a
young boy he doesn't feel worthy because
he's nothing like the legendary sea
snake he believes it should have went to
vaimon valerion however renera says
something that may have influenced
lucari's and unfortunately it may have
inadvertently led to his death raniera
says she had similar failings when she
was much younger but she decided she
could fix this by earning her
inheritance that advice may have led to
lecari's volunteering to hand deliver
his mother's message to Lord Baratheon
as a way of making a name for himself
now with that being said he might have
done it anyway because his older brother
Jace was eager to get involved anyway
after this is when rhaenys arrives and
reveals what happened at King's Landing
rhaenera and Damon are shocked when they
find out viserys has died Damon
immediately believes Alison was behind
the death of viserys now I gotta be
honest it is a little funny how Damon
seems so blindsided by this Revelation
he saw how viserys looked when he was
last in King's Landing now I'm not the
biggest fan of Alison or Serato either
but I don't know if I would have
immediately thought someone murdered
viserys I would actually be more shocked
if they said he was still alive but
maybe that's only me what really sends
renera over the edge is when she learns
aegon has succeeded her this is what
actually sends her into early labor
although I'm sure the news of her
father's death did help accelerate it as
well however it was aegon's coronation
that gave her a visceral reaction when
they find out rhaenys was a witness to
this Damon wonders of the exact same
thing every fan did when watching the
scene why didn't rhaenys burn them all
alive well she more or less says it's
not her fight and this is something we
will notice throughout most of the
episode rhaenys isn't so fast to stand
with either side she doesn't Bend her
knee when rhaenera is given her father's
crown and she doesn't agree with Damon
when he says melees is one of the
dragons who will help them in the battle
it was obvious raineys also wanted to
wait and see how her husband would react
to all of the new information I mean
after all Damon did behead his brother
vehman she didn't know exactly how he
would feel about that so I understand
why she held back her Allegiance during
some of the scenes the sudden shock of
all this information sends raniera into
labor and I thought this scene was very
interesting because it also revealed how
the dragons react to their Riders as
Rainier was in labor there were several
flashes to her Dragon Cyrax who also
seemed to be affected by her writer
suffering I thought it was a great way
of showing their connection with one
another it makes me wonder does rhaenyra
have a greater bond with her Dragon than
the others or do they all share this
same Bond once they mount their
individual dragons
the end of this episode did seem to
suggest otherwise when we saw Iraq's and
vagar do what they wanted regardless of
whatever command their writer was giving
maybe the dragons don't listen as well
whenever they feel their life is in
danger either way it seems viserys was
right when he said the targaryens having
control over their dragons is only an
illusion it's very interesting
nonetheless now back on Dragonstone
Damon goes full Daenerys Targaryen when
he has the men of the kingsguard swear
fealty to renera he understandably wants
to make sure they're loyal he reminds
them of who viserys named his Heir right
before he died not only did we see
Daenerys do the same thing to samwell's
father and brother but Damon also
recites one of her lines from the first
season of Game of Thrones he says if
they betray her they will die screaming
this is the same thing Daenerys said to
Mary mazdur unfortunately renera loses
her daughter and as described in Fire
and Blood the baby was malformed though
not as bad as I had imagined in Fire and
Blood it said that her daughter was a
monster but I would not go that far her
head was misshapen sure but that's about
it now during the funeral ceremony only
one of the Cargill Brothers arrived with
viserys's crown in hand the other cargo
brother actually stayed in King's
Landing to stay on guard with aegon if
you remember he actually ran away when
this Cargill brother was fighting sir
Kristen Cole now renera getting her
father's crown and having Damon be the
one who sets it on her head was an
amazing moment if you ask me everyone
bending the knee reminded me of when
this happened for Daenerys at the
beginning of the original show it always
feels as if a character goes through a
metamorphosis after this happens maybe
it's really only me looking at them
differently but it does feel like they
give off a different energy moving
forward it is meant to be a symbol of
leadership so that might be why I see
them in that light I actually do believe
in her even if I don't always agree with
everything she does afterwards renera
holds her first black council meeting
and I must say she rolls up in there
like a mob boss another thing I really
loved about this seen as how they lit
the table it made it look as if all of
Westeros was on fire maybe it's a little
foreshadowing for what lies ahead Damon
then recites a line directly from Fire
and Blood when he announces how many men
are on Dragonstone obviously their army
leaves a lot to be desired considering
they don't have many men at all and just
like in Fire and Blood we hear what
houses having sworn allegiance to either
side the veil Winterfell and storm Zen
haven't declared for aegon or raniera
yet although they all did swear fealty
to her many years ago it was easy for
them to swear fealty to her back then
when viserys did not have a male Heir
now Rainier is about to find out exactly
what their words are worth they're
suddenly interrupted when Serato arrives
with an offer from King's Landing aegon
will allow them to live and even give
rhaenyra and her son some land so long
as they stand down and swear fealty to
him it is interesting how things have
shifted during this scene when we last
Saw Damon and Serato face off on
Dragonstone rhaenyra arrived on Dragon
back and helped Serato get Damon to
stand down now she's there to stand
beside Damon and I must say I like it
much better Rainer sure knows how to
make one hell of an entrance and I guess
it is easy when you have a dragon Danny
always knew how to arrive in style also
the scene is heightened even more as the
Cargill Brothers better known as Kane
and Abel face off as well now that
they're standing on opposite sides once
again another line is recited directly
from Fire and Blood when Serato
describes how aegon has the upper hand
not only does he sit on the iron throne
but he also wears the conqueror's crown
and wields his sword and so on and so
forth now I actually thought runero
wouldn't even consider his offer but he
had an ace up his sleeve when he tried
to win her over through a motion he gave
her the letter from Alison which was
something from one of the history books
they read about nymeria it reminded her
of their once great friendship and she
suddenly realized what was at stake this
makes Damon Furious because he wanted
Serato Dead from the very beginning
this is when Rainer reveals aegon's
dream of A Song of Ice and Fire but
Damon doesn't know what the hell she
means viserys had never gave him this
information because he never intended
for Damon to succeed him like we heard
visera say this is only meant for those
who will Ascend the Iron Throne Damon
lashes out and grabs her by the throat
and I do Wonder was that because he
wasn't given the secret or is it because
he doesn't believe it and thinks it's
some nonsense visery said to make
himself seem more significant or maybe
Damon's only an [ __ ] they like having
us hate him in one moment then love him
in the next they hold another black
council meeting and that's when renero's
Sons Jason Luke volunteer to hand
deliver their mother's message to the
veil Winterfell and Storm's end this is
also more or less directly from Fire and
Blood since Jace is older he is given
what is thought to be the more dangerous
Mission whereas Luke would go on the
shorter mission to Storm's end not only
is his mission much faster but they also
thought they would win over lord
Baratheon much easier if only he would
have arrived before aemond and vegar
maybe things would have went differently
these final 15 minutes of the episode
were absolutely incredible now I've
always tried to imagine what Storm's end
would look like in my mind but I never
could have imagined this the seed of
house Baratheon was stunning in a very
dark and ominous sort of way when
lucarius landed his dragon and vegar
revealed herself from behind the castle
wall he should have got his ass right
back on his dragon and left he knew that
meant aemon was already there and he
obviously knows they do not like each
other now sure he would have looked soft
if he fled but hey sometimes you have to
live to fight another day as soon as he
walked inside and I saw aemon standing
next to Lord baratheon's daughter I knew
exactly how this would end I mean I've
obviously read Fire and Blood but you
never know what direction the writers
will go in and this scene would show us
they did make some alterations of their
own the reason Amon was standing next to
the daughter is because he already had
agreed to marry one of them something
Luke Aries was not willing to do now his
fate might have already been sealed but
I do wonder what Lord Baratheon would
have done if Lou Carey said he would
marry one of his daughters would that
have swayed him at all I'm not so sure
that it would have considering vegar was
right outside that's obviously not a
dragon you want on your bad side
especially when she's laying right
outside of your door just like in Fire
and Blood when Lou Carey says he cannot
marry his daughter Lord Baratheon sends
him away with a message of his own the
only difference the show left out was
some of the foul language now before
he's able to leave aemon stops him
because he's still angry about losing
his eye and let's be real I don't blame
him for still being upset either when
aemon revealed the sapphire in his eye
it sent a lot of fans into a frenzy I've
seen a lot of the fans on social media
wondering if this means aemon will
become the night king or a white walker
in the future well the answer is no as I
just said the reason why his eye is blue
like that is because he has a sapphire
in his eye it's not because he's some
halfway zombie or anything like that and
let's just say when aemon does
eventually die whether it's in battle or
of old age they do find his body and it
is very obvious it's his body for a few
good reasons so we know he doesn't go
and join the night King's Army so for
anyone wondering his blue sapphire eye
has nothing to do with the night King
the white walkers or the army of the
dead now back outside of Storm's end the
scene becomes genuinely horrifying as
Lou carries and his small Dragon try to
flee from aemond and vegar it feels like
something right out of a scary movie my
eyes damn near fell out of my head when
I saw vagar Fly Above her ax she
literally could have swallowed the
dragon hole if she wanted now if you've
read fire in blood it only seemed that
aemon wanted to kill lucaries however
this scene did not unfold that way here
aemon was having fun in his sick sort of
way the dragons did seem to be listening
to their Riders until they felt like
they were in serious danger then all
bets were off as soon as the racks Let
its flame go vegar was out for a blood
there was nothing aemon could have said
after this and this is what viserys
meant when he said the targaryens having
control over their dragons is only an
illusion aemond look genuinely shocked
by what happened unfortunately for him
and the realm no one will believe him No
One's Gonna think this was an accident
not after how he acted inside Storm's
end everyone will assume he did this as
a way of getting revenge for his eye if
only the dragon died maybe they could
fix it but we all saw the local and
raniera's face at the very end the dance
of the dragons and the war of Fire and
Blood has officially begun her
considering their offer has now gone up
in Flames now it's only a matter of when
and how they will strike back I don't
want to reveal that just yet so there
you have it ladies and gentlemen season
one of House of the Dragon is over like
I said earlier I will be making videos
every week during the off season I still
have a lot to say and it will not be
long before filming on the second season
of House of the Dragon begins like I did
with Game of Thrones I will follow House
of the dragon and make update videos on
everything they do while they're making
the next season so if you're a massive
fan of Game of Thrones House of the
dragon and A Song of Ice and Fire don't
go anywhere just yet there's a lot more
videos heading your way as always I want
to thank all of you for stopping by and
showing some love I hope all of you have
a great day I will see you again very
soon bye
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]